so the first thing you want to do is you
want to factor it so let's go ahead and
factor this in factors to X minus 4
times X plus 3 okay and that's greater
than 0 and then here's where the sign
analysis comes in we're going to set
each factor each group equal to 0 now
when we do that we're going to get
negative 3 and positive 4 ok so we're
going to plot those on the number line
negative 3 and positive 4 now we want
this to be greater than 0 not equal to 0
so it's not going to include negative 3
it's not going to include 4 if we put
negative 3 and that's going to be
negative 3 plus 3 is 0 0 times anything
is 0 but we want it to be greater than 0
not equal to 0 so again that's why these
are open so then what you want to do is
you want to pick a point in each one of
these three intervals ok so I'm going to
pick a point that's less than negative 3
say for example on negative 4 okay if I
put negative 4 into each of these groups
the main thing I'm concerned with is not
the number but actually the sign so
negative 4 minus 4 is negative 8 but
what we're interested in is that it's
negative and negative 4 plus 3 is
negative 1 but what we're interested in
is that it's negative and a negative
times a negative is going to give us a
positive so I'm just going to put a plus
sign right there in this interval here
okay now from negative 3 to 4 a good
point to pick would be 0 okay so let's
pick 0 and if we put 0 in 0 minus 4 is
negative 4 again it's just negative 0
plus 3 is positive and you can see a
negative times a positive is a negative
ok so I'm just going to put a negative
sign right there
if we pick a point in this interval say
like 5 we're going to get a positive
okay so 5 is our test value r going to
put a positive 5 plus 3 is 8 that's a
positive and 2 positive multiplied
together give you a positive right so
I'm going to put a plus sign here now
we're interested in where the inequality
is greater than 0 meaning where is it
positive so it's going to be positive
here and it's going to be positive in
this region here so if you want to write
the solution in interval notation what
you would do is you would say okay from
negative infinity okay over here
all the way up to negative 3 not
including negative 3 that's where we're
using the parentheses not the bracket
Union from 4 not including 4 to positive
infinity so this would be the